foreign
Todd is with us Todd is in Miami hi Todd
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello Dave thank you for uh taking my
call sure what's up uh I have a problem
with uh parents saying no to parents
uh
Let's uh monster I did your course I did
it back in 2016. it was hard it's one of
the worst things I went to I didn't even
know I was in debt so I want to thank
you for that sure
I've built up a nice little
question
well I mean some income properties you
didn't hear everything cooked in the
crock pot get everything I was supposed
to do you know uh and my mother's
husband passed no life insurance
knowing that they were together for 30
years now
she's in my hands because my you know
other symptoms can't take can't do
anything
so she wants a nice condo I get it I'm I
have a real estate license also so it
was kind of easy but it wasn't easy
because you have to put 20 down
who has to put 20 down
you we did yeah
well I bought it for her but I put my
name on the team okay so you bought a
condo for your mom to live in why why
couldn't she live in a room
she didn't that's what she wanted
how old are you
52. that's what she wanted
oh yeah well I don't care what she wants
and why are you saying it like
if she says it that's what it is like 52
years old
yeah how old is Mom
75 in good health yeah and and she has
absolutely no money
I you know when he passed I said okay
well this is good I mean they lived well
and I thought automatically you had some
kind of Polish I just
the way they were going and the
Christmases and the things
she have any money
well she has two pensions and Social
Security but it's not enough to cover
the expenses they just went up on the
HOA fees over there
uh and we had to put six months in
reserve so that's like six thousand
dollars so
uh and I want my kitchen done and I want
the this I said wait that's your mom
talking that's your mom talking you hear
him yeah
I bought the book I just told your
producer the guys I read the book two
times and I'm struggling I said no
yesterday which book
uh boundaries oh yeah okay yeah so the
answer is no
to all of these things you gotta start
learning how to say no
yeah so how much is I'm not getting much
phone calls or anything okay I don't
care how much is the condo payment
it was a uh the condo monthly payment
uh 972 okay and she's supposed to be
paying that
right and she has two pensions and
Social Security so she can pay a 900
payment
right right okay and the ho but there's
no bud
I want to know you doing this for your
mom what's the implication financially
for you
[Music]
down substantially uh I wanted to buy
some more income properties because I
want to retire
I work in construction and I don't want
to be you know uh I'm doing things to to
to change my whole career and it's um
what's your net worth Todd
my network uh I guess the two properties
I have about two hundred thousand
dollars Equity one
not about now what fifty thousand
dollars in savings
I have a small pension from a government
public government jobs I have yeah what
do you make a year
about 125. you do not have the money to
help your mother any further I know I
know you don't have enough money you
didn't call me up with a 10 million
dollar net worth if it was chump change
and you wanted to go fix the kitchen
fine but but she's basically completely
out of control emotionally and I don't
know where you got or she got the idea
that you're obligated to give her a
condo and fix the kitchen and and and
and and now when people don't respect
boundaries and Henry Cloud talks about
in the book boundaries and then you set
a boundary please don't expect them to
accept it graciously so I suspect her
little spoiled self's pretty pissed off
at you
yes Theory yeah so oh well oh well
I know that's right I'm sorry I'm back
on when you said and she want she said
she needs a nice you know is almost
making these demands on you have you
said to her mom I I you know I'm doing
the best I can with my money I I want to
help you get set up a condo yeah you can
afford it yeah and if you can't live
with that then uh I guess you'll need to
move and I'll sell the condo but I'm
well I'm willing to let you live here
I've already done this much and I I just
can't do any more and yeah I can't I
can't no you really can you don't have
any money you don't have enough money
I mean you don't have enough money it's
a math thing and so you you don't make
six hundred thousand dollars a year and
have 10 million dollars it's not that's
not your numbers so and you you you know
the reason you called here is you know
she's weird and out of control right
I know yeah I mean she's your mom oh I'm
sorry to say that but I mean that what
she's doing is whacked so you just gotta
smile and go nah
huh done all I can do sorry Mom love you
but not do any more my love does not my
love for you does not indicate that I
have to be out of control nor am I at an
age or a net worth where I take orders
from people are you the only kid Todd
no but I'm the go-to okay you're The
Golden Child the whole family and I've
got I said no like three times this year
and I've I don't get any more phone
calls that's all right you know keep
saying no it's good practice yeah you
just got to build your muscle and she'll
figure it out eventually she'll
understand that no actually means no
it's a complete sentence
it's hard when it's your mom but she's
she's being whacked dude yeah she's out
of control whack